alors qu'est ce que vous aimez faire de
votre temps libre moi j'adore la vie à
300 à l'heure donc je déteste ne rien
faire comme schirnhofer board
[Rires]
je prends les transports en commun
également
non mais du sport au bout de quoi comme
sponsor fitness course boxe
s'est mise très favorable jouer au
tennis de table non pas du tout va très
bien m les femmes à être pas des noms
mais c'est quoi au pas de passion c'est
le sport c'est pas une passion mais
c'est vrai j'en fais beaucoup ouais
c'est ça va ça c'est important quoi ça
c'est un très très dynamique donc si je
ne mets pas un peu de fard à côté
clairement il ya trop d'énergie avant
moi surveiller quelqu'un de très
dynamique un acte et des gens qu est ce
que vous êtes heureuse tout ce qui se
passe ah ben si je vous dis d'anvers
franchement je serais pas très gros que
je vous sors comme franchement je te
jure suivi et ont vite tu viens souvent
voir avec la miss chaque année et je la
sens diane encore plus content que
toutes les autres je sens vraiment un
enthousiasme fou non mais franchement ma
vie en plus d'être très sûr de vous plus
relax et
ce depuis 40 ans
c'est à dire que je suis là la miss
france qui a été titré la plus âgée j'ai
24 ans jean marc 25 pour l'année 2000
france donc forcément déjà ça donne une
maturité différentes ont vécu quatre ans
à l'étranger pour mes études c'est tuer
ou à madrid en espagne j'adore
[Rires]
j'adore j'adore l'espagne adore donc
forcément ça aide à les ans voilà c'est
vrai sylvie l'aléa les hypers allait
s'appeler fret on avait les 110
milliards 7 me d'ailleurs je félicite
que clément s'est classé dans les bons
ce mot qui nous mais on aurait eu un
concours de miss univers elle est prête
elle parce que c'est ça non mais ça il
faut encore que je travaille un petit
peu de défier la danse est mieux miss
univers vous allez faire des farces
univers elle choisira miss univers et
miss monde où elles veulent mais cette
mission vous êtes comme vous voulez moi
je vois c'est dans ce monde
par choix perso mais bon l univers c'est
sympa aussi tout est sympa à faire pour
qu'ils soient pas oubliées mais
j'entends tout est dit
j'entends aussi en fait j'ai une
question posée oui c'est marrant les
hasards données puisque je cherche un
bien immobilier en ce moment il ya
[Rires]
sûrement des contrats vous conseillez
mais moi là malheureusement je crois que
j'ai pas travailler tout de suite
pendant un an en immobilier
bien long terme ça peut alors on
aimerait vous voyez vous m face à l'as
qu ils font ce qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ceux qui disent que le
concours miss france et sexiste parce
que ça chaque année il ya des polémiques
d'autres concours voilà je sais que ça
vous rend fou ça à oui j'ai envie
d'écouter parce que je trouve formidable
et dont je parlais avec plein de
polémiques qui sont sortis le féminisme
etc moi je respecte la vie de chacun
parce que voilà chacun à chacun sa
définition et chacun voit les choses
comme il veut et ce qu'on peut être
féministe et fair miss france mais moi
je suis mes cris miss france et
féministe ouais bien sûr et j'avais
aussi un français mais c'est vrai si oui
j'ai comme didier n ya plusieurs
définitions des féministes notamment
celles qu'on a envie de mettre en avant
ses coûts c'est quoi la vôtre alors la
mienne c'est j'ai envie de fin pour moi
une féministe quelqu'un qui prend le
pouvoir de sa vie qui décide et parce
qu'elle veut et on ne lui dit pas ses
lois moi quand je monte sur la scène de
même que je suis aux côtés de situe
entre 18 et 24 ans qu'on prend le micro
devant des millions de téléspectateurs
conte défilent en maillot de bain je
veux dire je me sens plus femme que
jamais les plus féministes que jamais je
suis en train de montrer mes valeurs
devant des millions de français je veux
dire josé j'assume c'est ça me semble
plus messieurs fin je me sens vraiment
c'est important ce qu'elle dit c'est
très bien répond il fait trop chaud et
aussi on a envie de prendre la parole en
maillot on décèle moi c'est ce que je
fais tout le temps
manos prend la parole je chante chante à
rotich c'est comme ça je suis bien à
quoi je suis bien dans ma tête c'est
bien belles choses et j'assume
exactement mail d'avis et le défilé en
maillot donc voilà c'est qu'est ce que
tu dis aux gens qui lisent le défilé en
maillot de bain c'est insupportable
c'est ici on peut pas faire ça gilbert
d'ajouter que vous êtes pour oui bah moi
je suis pour parce que je trouve que
c'est une galvanisation de la féminité
je suis pas je suis pas contre tous ceux
qui disent que c'est rétrograde que
c'est une humiliation au contraire je
trouve que c'est une exacerbation de la
féminité mais ce que je voulais vous
demander c'est que est-ce que vous
personnellement vous avez subi beaucoup
de critiques depuis le début de votre
parcours là dessus des amis à vous des
connaissances qui voudraient ne fait pas
ça c'est vouloir c'est maintenant un
gars par sa voix perso mon entourage
personne pour le coup je viens de
mascouche pour moi miss france est pas
du tout un garnement la plaignante des
rendez vous sur franchement et puis on
peut pas dire que diane soir garde aux
céréales issues de l'ère moderne
c'est séraphine
la chose que tu mets de côté ses de ses
liens de comprendre que miss france est
une année mais après c'est un tremplin
incroyable seront et ça ouvre des
carrières incroyable d'un film de ken
avait fait miss france à la base pour me
rencontrer
de fil en aiguille elle est où elle est
la
seule à réaliser deux rêves bon gardien
si elle c'est le fait bien si elle est
travailleuse si elle est humble si si
elle aime son public elle pourra
travailler toute sa vie par rapport à au
tremplin de miss france est un show
qu'elle va bâtir via d'ailleurs depuis
le titre
depuis le début syrie dit que vous
rêviez de rencontrer est ce que c'est
vrai a bien sûr tina oui mais bien sûr
comme tout comme tous les comme tous les
autres
tous les autres baladeurs dont vous
rêviez de rencontrer bernard montiel
également il est important de ce plateau
sophie labbé c'est un moment fort pour
miss france mais c'est vrai la tension
gaulle et à la raison ce même faire le
tour des plateaux et tout ça mais on
attend son passage de la miss france ça
touche pas à mon poste mais à terme on
attend son passage au jt c'est vrai
voilà alors justement vous vous êtes
vous êtes en plus c'est lui et
aujourd'hui cette année c'est quand même
une année importante parce qu'il va
avoir un nouveau président ont peut-être
le même président qui patrim emmanuel
macron c'est important pour vous parce
que franchement ça va être c'est ça va
jouer aussi peut-être que vous allez
être confrontés aux candidats est ce que
c est ça va être une élection importante
aussi une miss france cette année vous
allez être celle qui va peut-être
connaître le nouveau président ou le la
présidente vous l'avez vu à chaque fois
je me tourne vers bernard montiel le
président sortant comme on dit asrar
hibou est un polluant de main
d'anciennes c'est important pour
l'argent pour bernard montiel non mais
c'est vrai c'est important pour vous pas
mais c'est vrai que je rencontrais
nouveau président après on mêle pas mis
ces politiques quand même ouais donc je
ne vois pas d'avis en tout cas sur la
politique ça c'est sûr vous allez voter
quand même oui ça non mais avance mais
seuls dans leur dirai jamais que
moi-même pour qui vous allez voter
maintenant ils français rex et non parce
que c'est important c'est le vote le
vote de miss france c'est votre rôle
dans les prochains mois il va être
important aussi parce qu'on veut poser
aussi des questions je pense là dessus
sur la politique vous êtes préparé à ça
ou pas du tout
je pense que j'ai une équipe autour de
moi qui ai bien sûr il est père
bienveillante excellente en vie j'ai la
chance d'avoir signé avec moi qui est le
meilleur mentor qu'on puisse avoir donc
donc non mais préparés pour l'instant on
n'a pas parlé de politique parce que
encore une fois on m'avait pas mis ces
politiques donc toutes les questions qui
seront autour de ça moi j'ai pas mon
opinion a donné tu es là dessus je
représente tous les français et tous
leurs idéaux donc j'ai pas de parler
dans la vie en général